die vor krieg inflation und
energiemangel im raum jetzt drängen sie
mit macht auf eine antwort wenn wir den
nächsten winter einigermaßen unbeschadet
überstehen wollen und es geht um mehr
als eine warme stube die politik muss
richtig klotzen mit voller wucht das
neue entlastungspaket jetzt in der
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
katja mast ist bei uns sie ist die erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführerin der
größten bundestagsfraktion der der spd
gesine lötzsch von der fraktion die
linke ist dort stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende hansjörg wirz ist
chefvolkswirt des bundesverbandes der
mittelständischen wirtschaft
und meine kollegin hannah suppa ist auch
anwesend chefredakteurin der leipziger
volkszeitung
frau lötzsch ein sammelsurium an
kompromissen auf dem niveau des
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenners das sei
das dritte entlastungspaket würden sie
diesen satz zu stimmen wir haben einige
tropfen einige tröpfchen und von großer
wucht ist nichts zu spüren obwohl ich
diese begriffe eigentlich auch gar nicht
mag also bei super und es muss rum zu
nutzen die leute sind in ihrem alltag
sehr damit beschäftigt den alltag auch
zu bewältigen und insbesondere menschen
die arm sind die wenig geld haben und
davon gibt es viel zu viele in unserem
land 14 millionen menschen sind
armutsgefährdet die werden glaube ich
sehr sehr genau schauen was kommt bei
ihnen an und ich glaube dass zu wenig es
geht um den kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner
das sehen sie genau so dass dieses also
ich finde ja dass diese drei parteien
da wurde mir frau macht sich ja nicht
mal widersprechen können auch gar nicht
so optimal zusammenpassen und von daher
wird häufig nur der kleinste gemeinsame
nenner gefunden und ich hoffe dass herr
lindner und die fdp sich nicht zu sehr
durchsetzen diese dieser satz stammt von
friedrich merz heute in der
generaldebatte den ich gerade zitiert
habe das heißt die opposition steht er
offenbar in einigen auch zusammen
frontmaske wuchtig scheinen diese partie
tatsächlich zu sein 65 milliarden euro
das eine menge holz präzise wie olaf
scholz das behauptet ist aber vielleicht
doch eher weniger denn viele sagen dass
die kleinen und mittleren einkommen
immer noch zu schlecht weg kommen
und das ist ja auch ein vorwurf gegen
die spd als für in der regierungspartei
na ja wir haben ja dem paket viel drin
uns was besonders wichtig die kleinen
mittleren einkommen zu entlasten ist ein
klarer schwerpunkt dieses pakets aus
meiner sicht dass severin da schon mal
wieder sprechen herr keller und
ansonsten gehen wir auch strukturell an
die preise am strommarkt und
letztendlich dann auch am gasmarkt dran
weil wir brauchen das strukturelle
veränderungen und schöpfen die über
gewinne ab ich finde das ist ein starkes
zeichen wir gehen auf die einzelnen
punkte dieses entlastungspaket noch mal
eins super wie reagieren denn die
menschen vor ort auf dieses
entlastungspaket hersteller noch
einigermaßen zuversicht also zumindest
es in dem umfeld das sie überblicken
können ich habe jetzt die renten
gasrechnung bekommt der kann aus den
politischen entscheidungen der letzten
tage aber auch der letzten woche noch
nicht so wichtig herauslesen was das
jetzt für ihn selber eigentlich heißt
und was ihm das bringt und ich glaube
dieser satz you never walk alone ist im
moment eher eine interpretation der
leute die frage wohin laufen wir da
eigentlich gerade
dabei den leuten kommt tatsächlich an
ein koalitions gezerre und einen
kompromiss finden und
gleichzeitig eine gasanlage die sie noch
weiter belastet und ich würde ihnen
widersprechen kleinen und mittleren
einkommen die fühlen sich gerade nicht
gesehen es geht nicht um die leute die
wohngeld bekommen die von hartz 4 leben
sondern es gibt tatsächlich um die
menschen die die klassische
mittelschicht sind und vor allen dingen
auch die wirtschaftsunternehmen die
kleinen und mittleren gerade in
ostdeutschland haben wir viele davon die
jetzt gerade nicht wissen wie es
weitergehen soll das ist eine gute
überlegung für die frage anhören
wird denn das entlastungspaket für sie
auch das prädikat
wuchtig verdienen wenn es um die kleinen
und mittleren unternehmen geht das ist
bedauerlicherweise nicht dafür es ist
vielmehr das gegenteil dass wir konstant
ihren und was auch unsere mitglieder uns
widerspiegeln
der mittelstand die mittelschicht kleine
mittlere unternehmen werden im
wesentlichen bei diesem entlastungspaket
nicht so entlastet wie es notwendig wäre
um ihre situation zu verbessern sie sind
vielfach
an den rand gedrängt sie fühlen sich
allein gelassen und wir bekommen
tagtäglich rückmeldungen dass diese
unternehmen nicht mehr wissen wie sie
ihre rechnung bezahlen sollen und große
bedenken haben dass die maßnahmen die
ergriffen worden sind alle drei
leistungspakete gemeinsam überhaupt dazu
geeignet sind wirklich kurzfristig
entlastung zu bringen wesentlichen ist
es ein umverteilungs paket und ich weiß
lass' mich hinreißen zu der aussage dass
es sich darum eine hochrisiko strategie
handelt und die regierung noch mal in
sich gehen muss um dort maßnahmen zu
ergreifen die tatsächlich in der basis
auch ankommen und die entlastung bringen
der tag der generaldebatte das ist ja ja
ein schlagabtausch ein
aufeinandertreffen unterschiedlicher
positionen man kann auch was seinen
gladiatorenkämpfe sind das vor allen
dingen zwischen dem bundeskanzler und
dem oppositionsführer friedrich merz das
war heute im bundestag nicht anders
gewesen dagegen für beide vor allem auch
für den bundeskanzler
unerwartet emotional zur sache und wir
sehen uns mal zwei rede ausschnitte der
beiden an es beginnt der
oppositionsführer 300 euro für jeden aus
sagt sie und ich bekomme das in diesen
tagen auch überwiesen
brauchen sie das brauchen wir das oder
gibt es vielleicht in diesem land
haushalte mit einem
durchschnittseinkommen von vielleicht
1500 1600 euro im monat netto die er
1000 euro gebraucht hätten statt alle
300 es wäre besser gewesen dass auf
diejenigen zu konzentrieren wir brauchen
und jetzt kommt das dritte das dient
dazu dass die bürgerinnen und bürger
durch diese zeit kommen dass die
unternehmen kommen durch die zeit kommen
und dass die arbeitsplätze gesichert
werden you never walk alone das ist das
motto dieser regierung
thomas mann könnte durch die liste
derjenigen die diese 300 euro
energiekosten nicht brauchen noch
erweitern zb mit den 5 die hier sitzen
wie wuchtig und diese oder wie ungerecht
und nach art von gießkanne ist denn
genau dieser aspekt der gehört zu einem
anderen entlastungs paket an aber wir
haben ja auch andere pauschal gestellt
beträge jetzt eben im den entlastungs
paket ist das wirklich so sinnvoll da
alle über den gleichen kamm zu scheren
also zuerst mal will ich festhalten dass
in dieser runde zwei leute ihnen auf
jeden fall nicht bekommen wenn ich frau
dazu nicht gut
bekommt ich nicht da bin wenn es bei
einem falsch falsche behauptung aber
offenbar nicht widersprochen ich weiß
aber andere sagen dass
wenn sie ihnen bekämen bräuchten sind
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr so gut
wie das ist der dass der auch diese
kritik war super hat ist ja gerade schon
angesprochen
dass das da möglicherweise eine soziale
schieflage ist dass man den 65
milliarden
vielleicht noch anders haushalten könnte
gerade in diesem bezug auf die na ja es
sind jetzt zwei unterschiedliche themen
weil die 300 euro die jetzt im september
ausgezahlt werden sind aus dem zweiten
entlastungspaket und nicht jetzt aus dem
65 milliarden paket aber das sind
details wichtig ist ja dass wir zum
richtigen zeitpunkt gesagt haben wir
sehen die immensen preissteigerungen für
die bürgerinnen und bürger und wir
suchen instrumente um letztendlich die
mitte über die ich vorhin auch schon
gesprochen habe zu entlasten und deshalb
haben wir in einer einmalzahlung für
alle die erwerbstätig sind oder im
selbstständig sind die 300 euro
beschlossen die sind ja aber natürlich
auch mit dem steuertarif der jeweiligen
versteuerung versehen das ist dann auch
in unterschiedlicher betrag je nach
einkommen aber das ist ja nicht das
einzige instrument ich hätte mir vieles
auch anders vorstellen können mit
sozialen staffelungen bei den
einmalzahlungen und so weiter aber ich
glaube dass die
energiepreise und die inflation bis weit
in die mitte hinein gehen die in unserer
bevölkerung also dass eine nachzahlung
von 1000 euro auch eine
facharbeiterfamilie trifft ich glaube
das ist unstrittig in unserer runde und
deshalb hatten wir uns dazu entschieden
in dem 65 milliarden paket sind
natürlich viele weitere bausteine mit
drin wohngeld hatten sie selbst schon
freien angesprochen
kindergelderhöhungen bürgergeld erhöhung
das sehr kräftige die kräftigste die es
jemals in dem bereich gab aber eben sehr
sehr viele instrumente die tatsächlich
die arbeitende mitte entlasten ich mache
mal ein beispiel was gar nicht so breit
diskutiert wird wir werden die grenze
der midi jobs auf 2000 euro anheben es
gibt viele menschen die in
monatseinkommen von 2000 euro haben
wegen geringen löhnen wegen teilzeit und
das sind diese entlastungen bei vollem
sozialen ausgleich übrigens treffen
gerade diese arbeitende mitte und des
treffens trifft vor allen dingen viele
frauen weil meistens frauen die
geringeren löhne haben oder in teilzeit
gibt es wir wirken geschichten die diese
sage ich mal diese diese zuwendungen zu
unrecht bekommen ich werde erst mal
andersrum anfangen wollen weil frau mast
wenn sie sagen ja da gibt es eine
einmalzahlung das ist schön und gut aber
wir haben menschen gesprochen bei uns im
gebiet in sachsen die haben erhöhung
bekommen von einer gasrechnung die vor
bei 140 euro lag und jetzt bei über 900
euro liegt das heißt diese einmalzahlung
egal ob sie jetzt im dritten
veranlassung sbe care paket bekomme oder
im zweiten ist schon in einem monat
verfrühstückt das heißt es ist es
verpufft es geht ja eigentlich eher um
sehr viel grundsätzlichere fragen
nämlich von strompreis bremsen und gas
deckeln oder wie auch immer man ist
jetzt bremsen wie auch immer man es
jetzt aus formulieren wird und wie es
dann auch kommt und da hat das dritte
entlastungspaket ja an der stelle nur
vage vor aussichten gebracht woran noch
gearbeitet werden soll und zu unrecht es
ist tatsächlich so dass es natürlich
viele menschen gibt die jetzt pauschal
das geld bekommen was sie eben nicht
brauchen ist es gut dass die
rentnerinnen und rentner und die
studenten jetzt bedacht wurden auch da
haben es wahrscheinlich auch nicht alle
nötig aber zumindest gerade auch in
ostdeutschland ist das ein riesen großes
thema dass die renten sehr gering sind
dass da jetzt nachgebessert wurde war
wichtig und elementar aber auch da ist
ja die frage ist das gießkannenprinzip
da so sinnvoll
andererseits ist natürlich auch bewusst
ist wenn man es kleinteiliger macht
natürlich ein verwaltungsaufwand auch
wieder höher ist das muss man
wahrscheinlich auch miteinander in
verbindung setzen aber darf ich
politische würden sie denn schließlich
märz zustimmen wenn er sagt eigentlich
muss unten geklotzt werden und irgendwo
muss ein schnitt gemacht werden wo man
sagt gut dass in zwei wohlstandsverluste
für viele andere auch aber dann ist
leute und da gibt es ein einkommens
gruppen die das leichter verkraften
können ja natürlich gibt es
einkommensgruppen jetzt leichter
verkraften und wir sagen jeder jetzt
nicht von milliardären also ja so wird
das ja schon klar als natürlich darüber
milliardär reden aber das ist glaube ich
ein anderes thema also wer in prekären
verhältnissen lebt wer ein sehr geringes
einkommen hat der muss durch
direktzahlungen entlastet werden der
widerspruch durch märz besteht nur darin
dass er weiterhin eintritt für die
schuldenbremse die
cdu/csu-fraktion hat ja auch vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht geklagt gegen
den haushalt also den vergangenen
haushalt so dass ich das keine
überzeugende politik empfinde ich finde
ich würde gerne über das wort
grundsätzlich anknüpfen wir müssen uns
doch grundsätzlich die frage stellen
warum haben viele menschen in unserem
land so ein geringes einkommen und ein
ehemaliger bundeskanzler gerhard
schröder hat man stolz erklärt wir haben
den größten niedriglohnsektor europas
nun will die spd mit gerhard schröder
nicht mehr viel zu tun haben das
verstehe ich dass anderen grünen aus
anderen gründen aber wir haben einen
riesigen niedriglohnsektor und das ist
natürlich auch eine riesige
herausforderung weil wenn man so ein
geringes einkommen hat und immer sich
fragt komme ich über den monat dann ist
das eigentlich ein kein guter und
normaler zustand und die sparkassen
haben uns ja jetzt auch gesagt sie haben
ja da einen gewissen überblick dass die
möglichkeit vom einkommen etwas
zurückzulegen inzwischen bei 60 prozent
der menschen nicht mehr gegeben ist also
wir müssen uns noch mal die frage
stellen warum haben eben viele menschen
in unserem land ein viel zu geringes
einkommen warum sind die löhne so
niedrig und jetzt ist die situation
quasi eskaliert aber schlecht was sie
schon feuer wir wollen das ganz breit
und jetzt auf fächern was dieses
entlastungspaket bringt oder auch nicht
falls stichwort unternehmen was brauchen
die unternehmen eigentlich um über den
winter zu kommen sie vertreten die
mittelständische wirtschaft hier da gibt
es sehr viel verärgerung ich glaube
knapp die hälfte hat möglicherweise
existenzängste gerade wegen der
energiepreise was es kommt ja auch die
die kritik dieses entlastungspaket käme
der wirtschaft zu wenig zugute was fehlt
und was brauchen sie
in erster linie ist es endlich klarheit
beendigung der orientierungslosigkeit so
wird es in weiten teilen der wirtschaft
empfunden und ich sage es bereits es ist
der eindruck entstanden dass die
umverteilung gehabt das haupt die
hauptmotivation gewesen ist für dieses
paket wenn es aber darum geht die
rahmenbedingungen für wirtschaftliche
aktivitäten in deutschland zu verbessern
dann müssen die rahmenbedingungen
verbessert werden das betrifft die
steuern und abgaben das betrifft die
bürokratie das niveau der bürokratie in
deutschland jedes jahr über 52
milliarden euro bürokratiekosten für die
gesamte deutsche wirtschaft und es
bedeutet natürlich auch dass
versorgungssicherheit und bezahlbarkeit
von energie gegeben ist und die
maßnahmen die bislang arg getroffen
worden sind sind meines erachtens nach
dafür nicht geeignet und habe ich
geradezu es müsste bei einem angebot
schafft der zweifelsohne vorliegt dafür
gesorgt werden dass jede kilowattstunde
die erzeugt werden kann auch erzeugt
wird um das preisniveau zu dämpfen
zumindest zu dämpfen den anstieg
verhindern das lässt sich wohl kaum und
was auch geschehen muss ist alles das
was selbst dazu beiträgt durch eigenes
handeln dass die inflationsrate nach
oben schießt müsste auf ein minimum
begrenzt werden es sind da schon falsche
weichenstellung gestellt worden unserer
ansicht nach als auch die übungen des
lohns angeht man kann ökonomische
gesetzmäßigkeiten nicht außer kraft
setzen es wird in der wirtschaft nach
produktivität entlohnt und nicht nach
wunsch und dem was man sich tatsächlich
auch müssen erhalten viele die hand auf
müssen auch viele die hand aufhalten das
heißt es gibt jetzt verteilungskämpfe
weil diese 65 milliarden selbst wenn
dann noch ein weiteres entlastungspaket
dazu kommen könnte vom meister aber auch
schon andeutungen heute gemacht
trotzdem sind die mittel begrenzt also
nicht alle die vorstellungen nicht alle
die wünsche von den privathaushalten
ebenso wie von den unternehmern können
umgesetzt werden ist er sich eine riesen
dem dilemma für dieses land ist
vielleicht doch zu wenig da und damit
alle zufrieden sein können mit dem was
sie brauchen um jetzt über den winter zu
kommen vielleicht unpopulär sein aber
ich meine wir haben mittlerweile
dimensionen erreicht die schon die
chorakademie rande gehen und daher
sollten auch die maßnahmen die ergriffen
werden ähnliche dimensionen annehmen es
gibt konkrete vorschläge seitens der
wirtschaft beispielsweise was die
verrechnung von verlusten angeht da
sollte große wieder vergangen werden
wenn er vom blumen aber vom zeitlichen
ablauf her mindestens drei wenn nicht
sogar fünf jahre dann
steuervorauszahlung auch hier könnte man
erleichterung für unternehmen geschaffen
das würde die liquidität erhöhen es gibt
ganz konkrete beispiele dafür was getan
werden kann um die unternehmen zu
entlasten und zwar jetzt und schnell
gerade heute hat das
bundesfinanzministerium bekannt gegeben
dass die wirkungen die
entlastungswirkung der 65 milliarden
euro in diesem jahr lediglich bei 13
milliarden liegen also viel viel weniger
als das was in aussicht gestellt worden
ist und von daher bin ich der auffassung
dass sie unbedingt nachgebessert werden
muss er muss noch eine schippe
draufgelegt werden was ist da ist das 1
eine schieflage im dritten
leistungspaket dass die wirtschaft da
das gefühl hat nicht mehr das gefühl hat
wahrscheinlich dass dazu wenig in das
getriebe geschüttelt wird damit am
laufen bleibt es gibt ja auch
industriebetriebe wahrscheinlich auch in
ihrem wahlkreis die die produktion
runtergefahren haben das ist ja höchst
in höchstem maße arbeitsplatz geführt
also zuerst mal sind ja viele der
instrumente treffen auch die wirtschaft
ich mach mal beispiele
frau super hat angesprochen wir brauchen
eine strompreis bremse ja die haben wir
vereinbart haben auch gesagt wir schauen
zuerst doch wird es auf dem europäischen
weg hinbekommen wenn wir das nicht
hinbekommen werden wir das national tun
das ist eine klare zusage ist auch in
den 65 milliarden eingerechnet und wir
werden das zurückgeben als strompreis
bremse davon profitieren natürlich alle
die versorger verträge das heißt mit
einem
energieversorgern versorgungsvertrag
haben werden davon profitieren und wir
wollen damit die bürgerinnen und bürger
ganz massiv entlasten also insofern sie
können zwar sagen das ist unkonkret aber
es ist eine ganz klare politische
verabredung und wir müssen ja noch mal
feststellen auch das vielleicht noch mal
zur differenzierung das strom- und
gaspreis unterschiedlich funktioniert
deshalb haben wir beim gaspreis wäre das
was am meisten die kosten treibt ja
nicht nur daran gearbeitet
seit dem ersten tag dieser regierung im
übrigen unabhängiger von russischem gas
zu werden wir bauen lng terminal also
flüssiggasterminals wir haben die
abhängigkeit von russischem gas von 55
prozent
ja ist nach wie vor hoch aber sie
funktionieren unterschiedlich deshalb
haben wir gesagt wir machen eine
expertenkommission weil es tatsächlich
noch mal an komplexität nicht zu
überbieten ist jetzt werden sie sagen es
reicht wenn ich es nicht schnell genug
das dürfen sie auch aber ich will schon
die ernsthaftigkeit hinter diesen
projekten hier hinterlegen dass wir auch
ganz klar den gaspreis im blick haben
das hilft auch dem mittelstand und im
mittelstand hilft natürlich auch dass
wir sagen wir haben ja ein bundesweites
programm das in energie und export
intensive unternehmen entlastet mit
direkten zuschüssen wir haben keine
programme und so weiter und bei diesem
zuschussprogramm das wollen wir weiter
öffnen das ist auch dann natürlich in
der umsetzung sind fragen zu stellen die
wir in europa abstimmen müssen aber es
ist die ganz klare vorstellung also
viele auch in meinem wahlkreis gibt's
bäckerinnen und bäcker die sich an mich
wenden mit ihren energiekosten das kann
ich auch gut nachvollziehen und ich
erhoffe mir davon dass wir solche
unternehmen mit in diese zuschüsse mit
rein bekommen und wenn das nicht der
fall sein sollte es kann ja sein dass es
nicht funktioniert dann müssen wir
nachsteuern das ist das letztendlich was
auch die klare inhaltliche becker schon
pleitegegangen
dann müssen wir nachsteuern wir müssen
aber die wege schritt für schritt gehen
aber ich will schon noch mal noch einmal
zu dem was im kern um uns antreibt wir
haben durch putins angriffskrieg einfach
er versucht uns hier in deutschland zu
erpressen und unsere bevölkerung zu
spalten und wir unternehmen jedwede
anstrengungen das nicht zuzulassen
deshalb ist mir auch wichtig dass an
vielen punkten gasspeicher und uns schon
gearbeitet worden ist weil das wichtig
ist für diesen winter aber weil es auch
strukturell wichtig ist für die
wirtschaft in unserem land weil ich will
weiterhin eine industriegesellschaft
also dass wir weiterhin industrie und
starke unternehmen haben und deshalb
müssen wir energie völlig
energieunabhängig werden nicht nur von
russland sondern möglichst überall und
deshalb arbeiten wir ja mit hochdruck
wir haben über zehn gesetzte vor der
sommerpause verabschiedet zum massiven
ausbau von erneuerbaren energien und das
hat der bundeskanzler olaf scholz heute
auch noch mal sehr deutlich gemacht wo
da auch die unterschiede zur
vergangenheit aber dass in einigen
jahren zur verfügung stehen also die
menschen bekommen ja ihre rechnung jetzt
und wenn sie hören expertenkommission
europa dann sagen das wird alles auf die
lange bank geschoben und diese 65
milliarden sind ja noch völlig unklar
wie haben das ja jetzt auch gerade schon
angesprochen dass sie eine information
bekommen haben dass in diesem jahr
erstmal 13 milliarden wirksam sind und
ich fand auch ein bisschen erstaunlich
wie naiv die bundesregierung
herangegangen ist an die fragen der
sanktionen natürlich reagiert putin auf
die sanktionen das ja völlig klar es
würde man gesagt hat das ist nicht
sanktioniert natürlich nicht aber er
reagiert so an der stelle muss uns eben
am meisten trifft und darauf war die
bundesregierung und ich vorbereitet weil
sie dachte naja wir können machen was
geben die sanktionen und er wird dann
schon weiter oder russland wird schon
weiter liefern das ist glaube ich eine
große fehleinschätzung gewesen und ich
muss ihnen aber widersprechen weil sie
sagen der mindestlohn wäre zu hoch der
ist natürlich überhaupt nicht zu unserer
meinung nach ist er sogar zu niedrig
wenn er nicht so niedrig wäre müssten ja
nicht so viele menschen um hilfe hilfe
beantragen und das finde ich eigentlich
wirklich eine fatale situation dass wir
so einen großen anteil
unserer bevölkerung haben dass die
menschen anträge stellen müssen quasi ja
ich sag mal das böse wort bittsteller
sind anstatt dass sie eine solide
finanzielle basis haben ihr leben
wirklich gut selber finanzieren zu
können und es geht das ist mir auch ganz
wichtig nicht nur ums überleben also
manchmal sprechen ja so als hauptsache
wie die leute haben es was zu essen und
köln heizen wir wollen ja ein gutes
leben wir wollen ja ein leben wo die
menschen auch sich entwickeln können die
an kulturellen veranstaltungen
teilnehmen können was ja auch wieder
arbeitsplätze betrifft in der kultur das
hatten wir ja nun gerade in der korona
zeit sehr schmerzlich erlebt wie viele
künstlerinnen und künstler doch in ihrer
existenz grenze geraten sind also ich
finde wir müssen auch unser anspruch wie
wir unser leben hier leben wollen auch
etwas anders formulieren und von ihnen
habe ich das nicht gehört frau macht
aber von mitgliedern der regierung die
sie unterstützen wenn ich dann so tipps
höhere also man soll nicht mehr so lange
duschen oder waschlappen wäre doch eine
schöne ich sage nicht dass sie es gesagt
haben aber vertreter der regierung und
das finde ich auch schon jetzt
ziemlich
flott doch etwas erweitern wir haben da
schon angesprochen es gibt ja eine ganze
reihe von leistungen aus dem dritten
entlastungspaket für die wirklich
bedürftigen die erst nächstes jahr kommt
ist nicht zu dieser 13 milliarden dieses
jahr erst wirksam werden und der rest
kommt später das gilt ja auch für diesen
bereich glaube das bürgergeld es geht um
die wohngeldreform die ja ein echter
zuwachs ist es geht um kindergeld und es
geht auch von den kinderzuschlag den
armen familien bekommen ab ersten januar
das sind jetzt noch dreieinhalb monate
ist ohnehin viel zu lange zeitraum bis
das geld dann fällig wird da komme ich
wieder zu den punkt von vorhin dass die
menschen kriegen zum teil jetzt ihre
rechnung und müssen auch jetzt schon
sehen wie sie darauf reagieren wir
berichten als lokalzeitung seit monaten
auch darüber wie die inflation auch die
menschen schon seit april haben wir die
ersten geschichten gemacht die großen
wie die leute verwundert auf ihren
einkauf gucken und sagen das kann ich
mir so nicht mehr leisten das ist ja
nichts was jetzt erst gekommen ist mit
diesen großen gas oder stromrechnungen
die jetzt kommen gleichzeitig haben wir
auch finden wir das vor zum beispiel in
leipzig gerade dass die kommunalen
stadtwerke ein darlehen von 150
millionen euro wir brauchen von der
stadt und überhaupt fähig zu sein an der
strombörse zu handeln wo sich natürlich
dann auch die frage nachrangig stellt
wie es in den nächsten monaten
weitergeht auch mit kommunalen ausgaben
was dann für die menschen da sein wird
aber ja das geld ist moment nicht da wir
haben der verbraucherzentrale gesprochen
im moment überrannt werden wie sich so
ein bisschen als lotse gerade sehen und
sind für zu versuchen die menschen schon
mal darauf hinzuweisen wo sie hingehen
können wo sie hilfe bekommen können wir
es gibt ja auch jetzt schon
möglichkeiten sich hilfe zu holen am
ende muss man einmal sagen dass die
krise natürlich auch ein bisschen
ungleich ankommt in den in dieser zeit
weil nicht jeder jetzt schon seine
abschlags rechnung bekommt wir merken
das auch wenn wir mit menschen sprechen
dass bei mich bei jedem kommt schon an
was eigentlich kommen könnte im
persönlichen erleben in den nächsten
monaten ich glaube deswegen werden wir
auch in den nächsten monaten auch eine
unterschiedliche wucht sehen inwieweit
da auch vielleicht ja die sorge nach
außen getragen würden dafür wenn wir
davon reden dass zumindest die etwas
besser gestellten
die nicht unterstützt werden können
denen man vielleicht auch etwas mehr
zumuten kann wenn die wohlstandsverluste
erleiden so wird das ja immer genannt
was bedeutet das eigentlich für branchen
die vom wohlstand der menschen sehr
stark abhängen also tourismus
automobilindustrie
unterhaltungselektronik rechnet sie da
mit großen einbrüchen so wie es einmal
ist festzustellen dass die energiepreise
explosion nicht nur diejenigen trifft
die direkte von betroffen sind sondern
es zieht sich durch die gesamte
wirtschaft die haben die aktuelle
beispiele gerade die auch in den medien
kursieren bezüglich
einzelhandelsketten und wenn ich die
zahl richtigen im auge hat ist seit 1994
der einzelhandelumsatz noch nie so stark
gesunken wie es jetzt gerade der fall
gewesen ist das heißt dass endlich wird
es alle branchen treffen unabhängig
davon ob er primär dort personen
einkaufen die über höhere einkommen
verfügen oder niedrigere einkommen
letztendlich dass die gesamte deutsche
wirtschaft treffen jetzt noch ein
anderer aspekt wenig
dass die zwölf euro geschichte an die
mit dem mindestlohn letztendlich muss es
um mehr netto vom brutto gehen und hier
hat der staat extrem gute möglichkeiten
eigenverantwortlich und auch ohne
rücksprache mit brüssel entscheidung zu
treffen es betrifft die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge es betrifft
die steuern dann kann ausgaben
reduzieren die strukturreform in den
sozialversicherungsbeitrag machen und
auf diese weise dafür sorgen dass die in
netto einkommen höher sind man kann
dafür sorgen dass die stromsteuer die
beim gewerbe strom 40 mal höher ist als
von der eu vorgegeben oder beim nicht
gewerbe strom 20 mal höher ist als nicht
von der europäischen union vorgegeben
dass man dort anfängt diese steuern zu
reduzieren auf das europäische niveau
und auch dafür auf diese weise dafür zu
sorgen dass die haushalte weniger
belastet werden also das sind
möglichkeiten die könnten jederzeit
ergriffen werden ich kann mir auch
vorstellen dass innerhalb der
regierungskoalition bei gutem willen
auch diese entscheidung getroffen ist
das nicht das prinzip linke tasche
rechte tasche wenn man
sozialversicherungsbeiträge zum beispiel
rentenversicherungsbeiträge absenkt dann
merken diejenigen denen diese beiträge
jetzt erlassen werden oder gekürzt
werden oder abgesenkt werden spätestens
als renten und dass sie wesentlich
weniger rente haben weil dann auch
weniger beiträge für sie eingezahlt
worden sind und steuerung
steuererleichterung fordern ja viele
gleichzeitig wird ja aber auch vom staat
erwartet dass er viel geld in die hand
nimmt um viele dinge möglich zu machen
und soziale härten abzufedern und nicht
immer gleich die schuldenbremse aus
setzt also das irgendwie beißt sich die
katze da ständig in den schwann die
ökologische soziale digitale
transformation der die ampel regierung
festgeschrieben haben koalitionsvertrag
mit der letztendlich in den unternehmen
umgesetzt und wenn man die unternehmen
über gebühr belastet wenn man ihnen
weniger zur verfügung lässt was
notwendig ist um diese investitionen die
gigantischen investitionen zu stemmen
dann scheitert diese transformation also
von daher studiere ich dafür dass man
den unternehmen mehr spielraum lässt sie
weniger einengt und vor allem endlich
anfängt bürokratie zu reduzieren es gibt
sehr sehr viele vorschläge der letzten
legislaturperiode sind die weitestgehend
ignoriert worden auch diese vorschläge
lägen vor man müsste einfach nur den mut
besitzen sich dort heranzuwagen und dann
gemeinschaftlich dafür zu sorgen dass
dieser große block von 52 milliarden
euro endlich abgebaut wird
ich glaube aber wir haben auch reserven
wo wir keine einnahmen täten also es ist
ja auch jetzt schon diskutiert worden
das ist ja aufgenommen worden die über
gewinnen steuer das haben ja auch in
jeder krise sowohl in der finanzkrise
als auch in der korona krise als auch in
dieser krise bestimmte
konzerne hohe gewinne gemacht über
gewinne und auch es gibt energiekonzerne
die wirklich profitiert haben das muss
man doch abschöpfen und deutschland gilt
ja immer noch als steuer spar tun als
das wäre ja gut wenn es funktioniert da
sagt nicht über gewinn steuer sondern
zufall zu gewinnen
richtige tun frau master werden sie
immer unsere unterstützung bekommen aber
sie müssen es halt - nun hat müssen
nicht doch selbstverständlich also mir
hat es sich hier haben als zehn jahre
für den mindestlohn gekämpft und als er
dann endlich ist es das schön finde das
ist eine richtige sache der mindestlohn
und wir haben schon für den mindestlohn
gekämpft als selbst die gewerkschaften
gesagt haben aber kommen wir zurück zu
den einnahmen also man hat die
möglichkeit über gewinne einzunehmen das
muss man natürlich der fdp auch dann
ordentlich beibringen die ist sondern
natürlich da gehe ich aber wir auf gutem
weg ja aber ich bin dagegen dass sich
die anderen parteien hinter der fdp
verstecken also hier versteckten den
jährigen hier die spd und die grünen und
wie gesagt deutschland gilt immer noch
als steuerhinterziehungs paradies auch
da haben wir ganz viele möglichkeiten da
muss natürlich das finanzministerium
auch ran und mit der kontrolle und mehr
prüfung steuer tiefenprüfung zu machen
und auf der anderen seite dann natürlich
hätte man reserven um die unternehmen zu
unterstützen die auch ehrlich ihre
tätigkeit sozusagen umsätzen von 90,9
prozent ja genau aber das ist ja gut die
anderen werfen natürlich ein schlechtes
licht und vor allem auf alle und vor
allen dingen fehlt uns dann im
bundeshaushalt die mittel oder fehlende
die wir für nützliche dinge brauchen
könnten frau passt diese zufalls gewinne
die besteuert werden sollen die sind ja
eine voraussetzung dafür dass strom
strompreis bremse funktioniert oder
funktionieren sollen ich glaube so etwa
75 prozent wenn ich selbst richtigen
kopf habe das
der durchschnittliche verbrauch soll
eben mit einem gedeckelten strompreis
möglichst billig den haushalten zur
verfügung gestellt werden wäre dann mehr
braucht muss auch erheblich höhere
preise zahlen aber die voraussetzung ist
diese besteuerung und daher gibt es noch
viele viele fragezeichen sie müssen sich
auf europäischer ebene einigen das in 27
ländern mit völlig unterschiedlichen
interessen da habe ich eine gewisse
vorstellung davon wie die diskussion
sich in den nächsten tagen entwickelt
ist das auf sand gebaut ist das nicht
auf sand gebaut dass sie dann
möglicherweise gar kein geld jedenfalls
nicht diese einnahme für die strompreis
bremse haben also zuerst mal woher
kommen die hohen strompreise das ist
vielleicht das ist kein keine
angebotsknappheit sondern wir haben ein
strompreisen deshalb sage ich auch
systematisch in die preisgestaltung
eingreifen das ist ja das was wir uns
vorgenommen haben weil die die preise
für strom sich immer an dem letzten dem
teuer zu gestalten kraftwerke orientiert
das sind meistens gaskraftwerken und
deshalb sind die strompreise hoch und
deshalb gibt es so viel über gewinne die
auf nicht in ordnung sind und die man
auch nicht in den unternehmen belassen
kann und deshalb wollen wir die
abschöpfen und wir haben ganz klar
verabredet wir suchen den europäischen
weg und wenn der nicht funktioniert
gehen machen wir nationale lösung das
ist die klare verabredung und deshalb
ist es auch kein wischiwaschi sondern es
geht darum auch in europa eine
gemeinsame lösung zu finden und ich find
bemerkenswert dass gerade heute die
europäische kommission genau auch noch
mal ein starkes bekenntnis zum
abschöpfen dieser über gewinne gemacht
hat und wenn es nach mir geht hat einen
mehr sie lieber morgen als übermorgen
aber seriöse arbeit an gesetzen und in
der regierung sind auch ich kann nicht
heute beschließen und morgen ist es auf
dem konto sonst braucht nun mal
gesetzgebungen und ja wir sind da
wirklich ein massives stück nach vorne
komme ich will aber noch mal hier was
zurecht rücken weil sie gerade auch mit
herrn falls noch mal wie ist es wenn man
die leute von
sozialversicherungskosten entlastet ich
habe ganz am anfang gesagt dass wir
diese mit job grenze erhöhen auf 2000
euro da machen wir genau dass wir sagen
sie müssen weil sie so ein geringes
einkommen haben die zahlen ganz oft gar
keine steuern sondern
sozialversicherungsabgaben das sagen wir
wir entlasten euch von den
sozialversicherungsabgaben aber
gleichzeitig garantieren wir euch
gleiche leistungen eurem gehaltsniveau
sprechen das ist ja die wichtige
botschaft also nicht weniger rente dann
automatisch sondern gleiche rente nicht
weniger anspruch im arbeitslosengeld
zusammen sollten sich die frage gar
nicht gestellt dass mehrfach erklärt
aber das ist natürlich auch ein bisschen
komplex deshalb wollte ich noch mal klar
genau deshalb habe ich auf die midi job
grenze hingewiesen das ist ein sehr
zielgerichtet des instrumentes trifft
kleine einkommen zeit seit einkommen das
was ich vorhin auch mit den frauen
gesagt habe was genau dahin geht die
arbeitende mitte zu entlasten und die
zwölf euro mindestlohn finde ich stehen
im verhältnis das ist ein lohn mit dem
man am schluss auch mehr in der rente
bekommt als die grundsicherung im alter
das ist längst überfällig gewesen dass
er das hinbekommen und ich bin wirklich
sehr froh dass wir das für die
bürgerinnen und bürger in dieser
fortschritt consult.com schlager der spd
bei der letzten bundestagswahl fast noch
mal ganz kurz zur zugewinn steuer wenn
das jetzt aus bleibt also man sich nicht
eigentlich das kann ja durchaus sein es
gibt ja noch andere rechtliche hürden
olaf scholz und kevin kühnert sind
sicher nicht immer einig aber da sind
sie sich einig dann gibt es einen
nationalen alleingang gibt es denn
wirklich heimat in dem in dem papier
revolution der ausschuss ja dass ich das
mal der realisierung schaut man machen
und weil es bei der bei der gaspreis
bremse komplexer ist haben wir diesen
expertenrat gegründet ich würde auch
gerne den bürgerinnen und bürger heute
schon sagen das machen wir 100 prozentig
und es funktioniert so und so das ist
aber leider
ein komplexität etwas umfangreicher und
deshalb agieren wir da anders aber
insgesamt
65 milliarden bloß weil sie jetzt fallen
gesagt haben für die familie
kindergelderhöhung in den ersten paketen
waren ja auch schon kinder mit
berücksichtigt sehr stark 100 euro
einmalzahlung 20 euro pro monat mehr
nicht angerechnet auf
grundsicherungsleistungen wohngeld
kinderzuschlag also zusätzlich wir haben
familien auch schon in den blick
genommen ich will dass nur noch mal so
klar aus arbeiten weil wir gerade ein
bisschen zwischen den paketen hin und
her sprechen was auch legitim ist
insgesamt geht es ja um fast 100
milliarden entlastungen für die
bürgerinnen und bürger aber viele dinge
die ihr die koalition auch versprochen
hatte oder angesprochen hatte als
zentrale projekte sind jetzt völlig
verschwunden also kindergrundsicherung
das aber nicht verschwunden das kommt
noch ja wann kommt es das ist ja die
große frage ich will ja nur mal ins feld
nur stellen innerhalb kürzester zeit vor
der sommerpause wurden 100 milliarden
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr das
ist jetzt mal durchgepeitscht im
bundestag aber diese
kindergrundsicherung an dir arbeiten
jetzt wo wir wurde mir gesagt sechs
ministern und das hört sich ziemlich
gefährlich an dass das dann ganz ganz
spielt kommt und diese 18 euro
kindergeld erhöhung die werden doch von
der inflation aufgefressen
also ich war jetzt gerade vielleicht
andere auch bei einschulungsfeier und da
spricht man natürlich mit den leuten die
kinder haben natürlich alle eine
schulmappe aber der wird in der familie
gespart zusammengekratzt und hefte sind
teurer geworden viel teurer geworden die
füllhalter alles und man braucht er
wirklich viel und man will das kind auch
gut ausstattung zum schulbeginn und da
sind natürlich so diese kleinen zu
schlüsse und diese erhöhung ganz schnell
aufgefressen und ich finde diese kinder
grundsicherung ist ja auch ein projekt
was wir grundsätzlich gut wenn die muss
jetzt wirklich kommen und wenn sie nur
plakatiert wird beim tag der offenen tür
und ist mir das zu wenig
sie hatten zum zur strompreis systematik
gesagt das muss abgeschöpft werden die
die über gewinne die dort entstehen man
kann aber auch argumentieren die stimmen
gibt es ja auch die sagen es ist ja
gerade der anreiz für unternehmen der
erneuerbaren energien dadurch
tatsächlich auch weiter innovation zu
fördern und weiter ausbauen zu machen
was natürlich könnte man jetzt sagen
wenn die die gewinne nicht mehr haben
dann auch wegfallen könnte was uns dann
wiederum in andere schwierigkeiten
bringt was wäre dann deine antwort es
geht jetzt erst mal um die
unverhältnismäßigen über gewinne die nur
indiziert sind durch den hohen gaspreis
die nichts mit den produktionskosten und
der produktion im strombereich zu tun
haben und die ausschließlich getrieben
sind von den internationalen gaspreis
märkten sag's mal so und deshalb halte
ich das also sind klasse krisengewinner
über diese gas verknappung die putin
verursacht jetzt mal kurz und das finde
ich in einer situation wo ich sie mir ja
auch sagen die leute haben das jetzt auf
der rechnung
finde ich das unverhältnismäßig dass das
und wiederfinden des unverhältnismäßigen
wollen dass deshalb abschaffen und den
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
zurückgeben innovationsförderung machen
wir ja auch an vielen punkten haben
heute die haushaltsdebatte im bundestag
gehabt wir investieren weiter über 50
milliarden in innovation und
investitionen für die zukunft und
natürlich gibt es da andere instrumente
für und diese unternehmens sagen können
ihnen ja das auch nicht für immer zu
sagen das ist ja auch überprüfen ob das
am ende des tages stimmt dann würden sie
eine bürokratie aufbauen woher folgt mir
sagt ich muss die bürokratie wieder
abbauen das also dass das machen wir
dann anders
möchte man missfallen zum ausdruck
bringen dass in dieser situation darüber
gesprochen wird wie unternehmen über
gewinne zufalls gewinne entzogen werden
wir sollten sich gedanken machen wie die
masse der unternehmen nämlich die 99,9
prozent die mittelständische kleinere
mittelständische unternehmen sind wie
die entlastet werden können und nicht
die paar wenigen die über gewinne
erzeugen das sollte im wesentlichen
darum gehen dort maßnahmen zu ergreifen
die schnell wirken nicht erst im
kommenden jahr und die schnelle
entlastung creme und mein hauptziel
petitum wäre der verzicht auf die
gasbeschaffung umlage von 34 milliarden
euro das ist ein gigantischer bürokratie
haben wir das ist eine umverteilung die
völlig überflüssig ist die unternehmen
die davon profitieren würden sollten
durch über einen schutzschirm
abgesichert werden so wie das in der
korona pandemie auch gemacht hat das
ging schnell und unbürokratisch und hat
für viele soziale verwerfungen nicht
besorgt und ein argument nochmal zum
mindestlohn die politik die politik hat
damals argumentiert durch die einführung
des mindestlohns das system wird nicht
politisiert es gibt eine
mindestlohn-kommission die orientiert
sich eine tri flow entwicklung und gibt
dann empfehlungen an die politik und die
politik entscheidet da es wurde immer in
abrede gestellt dass er zu irgendeinem
zeitpunkt die politik eingreift und
unabhängig von den wirtschaftlichen
entwicklungen her von den tatsächlichen
daten her löhne festlegen das ist der
dammbruch gewesen dass die damals
geäußerten bedenken haben sich leider
materialisiert wir sind in der sozialen
marktwirtschaft extrem gut damit
gefahren dass arbeitgeber und
arbeitnehmer in tariff lohnverhandlungen
die tariflöhne festlegen und dass der
staat sich rausgehalten hat und ich weiß
es selbst ich komme aus einem vom land
niedersachsen bei uns ist es so dass die
ja derjenige der spargel anbaut der
blaugrana anbaut oder in dithmarschen
kohlköpfe geerntet dass der rat darüber
sich gedanken macht wie er zukünftig
noch seine produkte zu einem preis
produzieren kann dass er auch noch eine
chance hat in deutschen supermärkten mit
anzukommen weil es ist eine völlig
unhaltbare situation das sparen und land
aus spanien hier günstiger verkauft
werden als dort verortet hier in
deutschland geerntet werden und da
spielt bedauerlicherweise verletzt sie
wir müssen wir vergeben spielen die
zwölf euro auch leider eine rolle weil
es bleibt dabei ökonomische
gesetzmäßigkeiten kann man nicht außer
kraft setzen es kann nur entsprechen der
produktivität entlohnt werden alles
darüber hinaus kostet arbeitsplätze also
ich teile wenn sie das tröstet ihre
publikum sogar als umlage und
vollständig ich finde auch das ist eine
sache die nicht zumutbar ist und man
müsste hätte es genauso wie in der
kroner zeit analog sowie wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds man auch hätte noch
wird mehr sozusagen
bedingungen ausstatten können aber
daraus könnte man ja auch lernen dass es
eben über das steuersystem stützen
müssen und nicht diese gigantische
umlage ich finde auch wichtig sie haben
jetzt beispiel das land aus der
landwirtschaft aber es gehören natürlich
auch zu klein und mittelständischen
betrieben zum beispiel
sozialeinrichtungen wichtige
einrichtungen wie krankenhäuser die ja
auch alle davon betroffen sind ich war
jetzt gerade in meinem wahlkreis wenn
man sich ja alle briefe pressen
abgeordneter johann kreis und da wurde
mir erzählt dass erstmal der
energieversorgern kündigt hat um völlig
neue verträge machen zu können und das
sind natürlich alles
problematiken die man ja auch sozusagen
treffen muss oder wo man entsprechend
reagieren muss und darum sagen wir wir
brauchen ein deckel auf die preise und
das ist natürlich auch möglich das
gibt's ja auch in anderen ländern der
europäischen union und ich kann nur
davon abraten ewig auf die eu zu warten
ich würde gerne noch auf einen anderen
aspekt in dem zusammenhang kommen die
oppositionsparteien im bundestag haben
wir verschiedene möglichkeiten
widerstand zu leisten oder eigene ideen
einzubringen
sie bringen gesetzentwürfe ein die in
schöner regelmäßigkeit von der
regierungsmehrheit abgelehnt werden sie
könnten auch im fall eines falles
untersuchungsausschüsse
beantragen das ergebnis dieser
untersuchungsausschüsse ist auch
durchaus überschaubar entscheidet man
sich also auch gern für den
außerparlamentarischen protest dafür hat
sich ihre partei jetzt entschieden gegen
die belastungen zu protestieren in form
von
montagsdemonstrationen bei haben sie
möglicherweise
unliebsame
ja die damit machen die da beteiligt
sind wollen sich hin von den ganz
rechten da
distanzieren das ist die entscheidende
frage sind natürlich die inhalte und wir
haben zu demonstrationen aufgerufen in
leipzig war er am montag ein großer sie
haben mir berichtet dass sie das auch
kurz gesehen haben wo die die forderung
ganz klar waren also die sozialen
forderungen die forderung nach dem preis
deckeln für energie für gas und strom
und da unterscheiden wir uns ja ganz
klar von den recht außerdem wenn wir
eine demonstration anmelden dann sind
wir der veranstalter und können wir auch
entscheiden ob bestimmte transparente
lösungen dort geduldet werden oder nicht
ich finde nur dieser versuch also da
könnten ja auch recht bekommen ist es
wichtig dass man sagt wir können den
rechten noch nicht die straße überlassen
wir können uns doch jetzt nicht
verstecken im wohnzimmer oder auf der
couch dazu aus dem fenster gucken und
sagen oh gott die rechten protestieren
was machen wir da also das ist ja auch
unsere aufgabe als linke opposition als
soziale opposition diese diesem protest
zu sammeln und vor allem daraus auch
forderung zu formulieren die wird
natürlich auch im bundestag einbringen
sie haben gerade glücklich auf der
montagsdemo gewesen was haben sie denn
da erlebt jetzt das war die erste von
diesen angekündigt jetzt war die erste
und es wurde ja auch alles etwas herbei
geredet in den vergangenen monaten gut
winter und heißer herbst so wie es die
linkspartei ja auch selber formuliert
wir waren es uns vorstellen sind auf dem
historischen augustusplatz von 1989 die
friedliche revolution stattfand und wir
hatten zwei seiten geteilt durch die
straßenbahnschienen auf der einen seite
die linkspartei ein paar tausend mehr
transparente konnten da zwar
kontrolliert werden von ihnen aber auf
der anderen seite hat sich tatsächlich
durchaus auch das who is who der
rechtsextremen szene in deutschland
versammelt wir hatten jürgen elsässer da
wir hatten holocaustleugner nicolai
lehrling da die freien sachsen und am
ende auch eine mischung von vielen
menschen die sich durchaus sorgen machen
und die auch durchaus wütend sind
manchmal nicht ganz differenziert auf
wehen und weswegen eigentlich die aber
zum teil sogar zwischen den
veranstaltungen und gelaufen sind wir
haben menschen gesprochen die sich
eigentlich als links bezeichnen würden
die aber sagen sie fühlen sich links
nicht mehr zu hause weil sie dort als
rechts bezeichnet werden wenn sie eine
andere position zu russland politik
haben oder früher hatten und es jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen auf der suche
sind danach was der neue weg sein könnte
und auf der anderen seite aber auch
nicht sich richtig fühlen weil das eben
eine rechte richtung ist und da haben
sie ganz schön was los getreten und da
muss man in den kommenden monaten gucken
ob sich davon abgrenzen können es wird
glaube ich eher bündnisse geben müssen
damit es eben jetzt nicht politisch
kapital das nach außen ist der begriff
montagsdemonstration den haben die
rechten ja schon seit langer zeit
gekapert um absurderweise sich mit der
ddr opposition auf eine stufe zu stellen
das machen sie jetzt aber auch das ist
ähnlich absurd sie haben viele alt kader
der sed war ja von ihrer partei gelesen
wir haben ja klar dass ich besser am
dienstag zu demonstrieren ja also wir
haben ja ganz deutlich gesagt also
gewinnen dass jan kein wochentag diese
demonstration fand am montag in leipzig
statt es gibt in ganz vielen städten
unseres landes
unterschiedliche protestform
kundgebungen das ist also nicht an den
wochentag gebunden und ich finde das
auch nicht seriös jetzt also ein stempel
drauf hauen zu wollen das ist eine
montags sache das ist für uns sich an
den wochentag gebunden bei uns an die
inhalte die produkt ganz kurz nur noch
30 sekunden vor massa schulz ich würde
ich will einfach rein und machen der
wand ungefähr 4000 leute auf der straße
ich rede lieber über 80 millionen weil
julia belot gilt für alle und wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass wir den blick auf alle
in unserer bevölkerung nicht sollen sie
dafür dass man die rahmenbedingungen so
verbessert dass es der wirtschaft gut
geht weil menschen die arbeit haben die
ihr von den früchten ihrer arbeit den
wohlstand genießen können haben keine
zeit und keine muße sich auf
demonstrationen aufzuhalten sondern
genießen ihre fürchtete arbeit ich
bedanke mich bei katja mast bei gesine
lötzsch bei hanna super und bei
hansjürgen gölz liebe zuschauer morgen
in der phoenix runde putins krieg gegen
die ukraine mehr waffen oder mehr
diplomatie
weiteres und aktuelles jetzt bei
phoenix der tag mit thomas bade darin
ausführlich noch einmal die
generaldebatte des bundestags bleiben
sie bei uns
[Musik]